and you heard her she just mentioned it
New York City uh and the trade-offs
they're making based on the money
they're spending well not long ago in
2021 Democrat New York city mayor Eric
Adams vowed to cherish and protect all
illegals he said this quote we need to
ensure that undocumented immigrants
receive healthare and protection that
ice is never in a position to partner
with the police department and harm them
we also need to make sure we treat them
with respect and dignity the dignity
they deserve also according to Eric
Adams the tired the poor and the huddled
masses yearning to breathe free are all
welcome in the big
applea that was then and this is now
with nearly 70,000 illegal immigrants in
New York City shelters you heard that
right and more on the way every single
day mayor Adams is no longer so virtuous
in fact thanks to a new emergency order
in the city Adams will be turning away
buses full of migrants illegals if they
don't meet certain conditions mayor
Adam's new message to illegals is simple
don't come to New York City you're not
welcome here now with reaction former
Trump senior advisor Steven Miller and
Florida Congressman representative
Michael wall step did he believe it then
and now it's just too tough to be that
virtuous anymore or is it political why
the about
face he was a fraud then and he is a
fraud now and I will tell you why
because if he actually cared at all
about the Safety and Security of the
people of New York City he would
terminate his status as a sanctuary City
and he would announce immediately that
the New York City authorities the police
departments the rent Department the
housing department every single
institution in the city will be taking
down immigration information taking down
immigration status forwarding to the
federal government and making sure that
the next Administration will have that
information to carry out deportations he
could do that right now but he does not
do it because he's still a faithful
servant a faithful member of the
Democrat Party who is committed in his
heart to a regime of open borders and
until he says we want these people to be
deported out of the country I don't take
seriously one word out of the mayor's
mouth well you know he has said very
recently it's not that we don't want
them we just need to spread them out
equally across the country there are
over 100,000 towns and cities why can't
everyone have the amount of illegals
that New York City has but
representative Waltz I noticed that
Florida's not having this problem
weather's a lot nicer there be a much
better destination this is actually a
policy question like why aren't illegals
going to Florida why are they going to
New
York well actually Pete uh there may be
yeah we can't get a straight answer from
uh the Department of Justice and from
DHS on exactly where these people are
being shipped in the middle of the night
uh and and what numbers uh and how
they're being taken care of but you know
what's so rich uh from from mayor Adams
and also the mayor of Denver the mayor
of Chicago is I mean in the case of New
York this is 67,000 that he's having to
deal with out of the over 10 million uh
in the New York City uh metropolitans uh
and and area uh look that's a fraction
of his population but you look at the
border communities in Arizona Texas and
elsewhere I mean you're talking 100 to
200% of their population so why is it
okay all these years that Texas's
hospitals schools infrastructure and
their dollars are being exhausted and
their citizens their veterans aren't
getting the services that they need but
suddenly when New Yorkers uh are barely
affected with a fraction of their
population then it's a national
emergency and here's one other thing
Pete the solution when you actually pull
the thread whether it's Adams or the
Democrats in Washington DC the solution
is to throw more money at it we should
have more shelters we should have more
hotel rooms uh and they're frustrated
with Biden because he's not spending
more money not because he's going to
actually close down not not closing down
the border and I promise you uh if the
Democrats get their way all they will do
is just flood more of our viewers your
viewers taxpayer dollars uh at this
problem rather than actually just change
policies and go back to what president
Trump did which is forced the most
left-wing president in Mexican modern
history to put his National Guard on his
Southern border and shut it
down that's exactly right uh they first
of all their their budget is already is
disaster in New York but Stephen what
they do is then they say here's all this
money here's all these hotel rooms
here's all these resources for illegals
yet there are homeless vets there are
you know people in any of the five
bureaus who can't get basic Services I
mean to me this is the inversion
completely of America First the
rejection of American citizens on behalf
of a reception of illegals he'll yell
about it but there's a there's a
political play here I mean there's a
reason the white house isn't changing
their
strategy every single thing you are
seeing is deliberate and purposeful from
the day Biden came in he terminated
every Trump removal and repatriation
policy and replaced it with a mass
release machine a mass resettlement
operation and all Democrats have ever
asked for are two things they want
amnesty and citizenship for illegals and
they want more money to place them in
shelters around the country more
taxpayer dollars they don't want the
problem solved they want the problem
accommodated and accelerated at and this
has a very direct connection to the
topic in your first segment about
President Trump being removed from the
ballot because in both cases what you
have is a war on American democracy
American voters are given no control
over their borders who can enter the
country and now they're being deprived
of their right to choose their next
president there is a war on Democracy in
this country and it is being waged by
the party of Joe
Biden yeah they're autocrats uh they
don't care about average people yeah go
ahead last word convers and let me just
add to that we were we were just a year
thank God we got the majority you
remember Nancy Pelosi's hr1 her first
voting Bill uh was to lower the voting
age to 16 to flood the country uh with
blast balloting and basically make the
country be able to ballot Harvest like
New York and California does so it's
it's not just the immigration it's not
just both uh Secretary of States and Das
going after president Trump it's also
the Democrats in Washington trying to
fundamentally change how we vote this is
a full-fledged across theboard assault
step's absolutely right and we need to
see it for what it is and we need to
wake up to it and fight like hell to
stop
it you're exactly right I mean the
Democrats worship one God and it's the
god of government and power and control
and expanding that power control and
we're seeing it power on every level
Congressman wals Steven Miller thank you
both hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else